thomas que doit-on retenir de ce long
discours à des manuels d'un cran
ce qu'on retiendra c'est évidemment
cette date le 11 mai date annoncée de la
fin de vos confinement date annoncée par
le président de la république qui a
affirmé que le consultant les plus
strictes étaient le seul moyen d'agir
efficacement contre cette épidémie
il ne faut ni renforcé mis alléger les
mesures de confinement ce sont les mots
du président de la république alors
concernant le 11 mai il a parlé d'une
réouverture progressive des différents
établissements scolaires je propose
d'écouter le président l'a dit qu à
partir du 11 mai nous rouvrirons
progressivement les crèches les écoles
les collèges et les lycées
c'est pour moi une priorité car la
situation actuelle creuse des inégalités
trop d'enfants notamment dans les
quartiers populaires dans nos campagnes
sont privés d'école sans avoir accès au
numérique et ne peuvent être aidés de la
même manière par les parents dans cette
période les inégalités de logements les
inégalités entre familles sont encore
plus marqués c'est pourquoi nos enfants
doivent pouvoir retrouver le chemin des
classes
le gouvernement dans la concertation
aura à aménager des règles particulières
organisée différemment le temps et
l'espace
bien protégé nos enseignants et nos
enfants avec le matériel nécessaire pour
les étudiants de l'enseignement
supérieur
les cours ne reprendront pas
physiquement jusqu'à l'été le
gouvernement précisera pour chacun la
bonne organisation qui sera nécessaire
en particulier pour les examens et les
cons
le président a public a également
affirmé que le lundi 11 mai pourrait
signifier le retour au travail d'un
certain nombre de français en revanche
pas de réouverture pour ce qui concerne
les restaurants ou encore les cinémas et
puis il a émis également l'hypothèse que
les personnes les plus vulnérables les
personnes âgées les personnes malades
puissent rester en confinement un peu
plus longtemps au delà donc de cette
date date du 11 mai le président de la
pluie qui a également fait un point sur
les ratés session c'est son nom les
ratés qui ont connu le début de cette
épidémie pas assez préparés à cette
crise avec pas assez de matériel c'est
une question qui est évidemment revenu
beaucoup ces derniers temps at on les
moyens de combattre cette épidémie à la
question des masques il ya également la
question des tests et là dessus le
président de la république s'est
prononcé en outre nous aurons à partir
du 11 mai une organisation nouvelle pour
réussir cet état
l'utilisation la plus large possible des
tests et la détection est une arme
privilégiée pour sortir au bon moment du
confinement
d'ici là et dans les prochaines semaines
nous allons continuer d'augmenter le
nombre de tests faits chaque jour ses
skis depuis quinze jours et fait durant
les semaines à venir j'ai demandé que
ces tests soient d'abord pratiqué sur
nos aînés nos soignants et les plus
fragiles et que nous puissions continuer
de mobiliser partout tous les moyens de
faire des tests c'est à dire tous les
laboratoires publics et tous les
laboratoires privés
le 11 mai nous serons en capacité de
tester toute personne présentant des
symptômes n'allons pas testé toutes les
françaises et tous les français
ça n'aurait aucun sens mais toute
personne ayant un symptôme doit pouvoir
être testé les personnes ayant le virus
pourront ainsi être mises en quarantaine
prises en charge et suivi par un médecin
pour accompagner cette phase
plusieurs innovations font l'objet de
travaux avec certains de nos partenaires
européens comme une application
numérique dédié
qui sur la base du volontariat et de
l'anonymat permettra de savoir si oui ou
non on s'est trouvé en contact avec une
personne contaminée
vous en avez sûrement entendu parler
le gouvernement aura il travaillait il
ne faut négliger aucune piste aucune
innovation mais je souhaite qu'avant le
11 mai nous a semblé puisse en débattre
et que les autorités compétentes puisse
nous éclairer
car cette épidémie ne saurait affaiblir
notre démocratie ni mordre sur quelques
libertés
parmi les autres annonces du président
de la république il ya donc cette
promesse d' accroître les aides aux
entreprises ou encore d'aider les
familles les plus modestes avec les
enfants ainsi que les étudiants
précaires le président de la république
qui a fait preuve d'une humilité nous
n'avons pas les réponses à toutes les
questions et c'est d'ailleurs une des
raisons pour lesquelles les contours de
ce déconfinement pourront continuer à se
redessiner dans les prochaines semaines
avant donc cette date annoncée ce soir
par le président d'habitat date le lundi
11 mai jour donc d'état finale merci
thomas bonnet